[Music]
there's more there's totally more than
always more
[Music]
and I'm from London and random I'm
Thomas okay
hi I'm Jude hey I'm [ __ ] yeah this is
Philadelphia for Budapest
[Music]
my name is Ruth I'm from the UK I'm also
here with my milk collective which is
over in the corner there which is life -
I think the web platform is a really
really interesting platform for making
art it's because of its openness its
ease of use its consumer ability by
everybody its connectivity like the web
is everywhere and for everybody which i
think is exactly what artists
[Music]
[Music]
so my talk was about maintaining bowel
and it was kind of just like my story of
how I got involved in the project and
then kind of like I shared a few stories
about what it's like to be a maintainer
keep the internet weird is a talk that
I'm giving to let people know that there
are communities available now that we
have that will be able to help you
foster that kind of growth and feeling
of inclusivity and code exploration and
that you just have to know where to find
them my talk was about compression and
were specifically about HTTP compression
so I was talking about being able to
kind of compress out your bundles before
you serve them up
[Music]
I saw this tweet earlier that kind of
summarizes really well whose was the Jay
s come for you feels more like a
festival than maybe the classical tech
conference and I think this is really
really nice to see because that's kind
of what we were trying to do I think
technology and the tech industry can be
only about engineering and frameworks we
really have to focus on the human aspect
of it and that's why we will never stop
having the stocks and we will never
never stop challenging the industry in
the way we do and that upsets some
people but I think that's good because
that creates a certain discomfort and
that drives change
[Music]